m 490 5 youtube videos podcasts apps
gehört für uns alles absolut zum alltag
dazu aber wo man dass ich noch nicht so
ganz verstanden hab ich manchmal das
gefühl das sind unsere unis anstatt
digital zu lernen sitzen wir in
ungemütlichen vorlesungssaal wir uns
zwei stunden langen monolog anhören m
490 5 reporterin annika säuberlich hat
sich mit diesem thema digitalisierung an
der lmu heute auseinander gesetzt und
ist hier bei mir
annika warum wird hier immer noch so
wenig gemacht die technik ist doch
eigentlich mittlerweile weit genug
ja eigentlich schon aber es ist
natürlich auch ein zeitaufwand und auch
ein kostenfaktor aber theoretisch stehen
sogar die fördergelder zur verfügung
aber die werden trotzdem nicht richtig
genutzt also gerade viele ältere
professoren haben einfach noch so eine
skepsis gegenüber dem internet und
trauen sich nicht sachen auch einfach
mal auszuprobieren
das hat mir auch marcel ohren schale
erzählt er ist studentischer mitarbeiter
bei dem projekt philo kaarst ich habe
festgestellt bei den letzten tagungen
und gesprächen mit anderen profis die
angst haben ihre inhalte zu
veröffentlichen die die epidemie ist es
so online und digital ist ein mythischer
welt wo es ganz gefährlich ist und wo
alles gegen sie verwendet werden kann
das ist gerade viele cast gesagt was ist
das genau
al soofi lukas ist ein digitales
lehrangebot für studierende der
philosophie
das was jetzt digitales lernen angeht
wirklich fortschrittlich ist das hat der
doktor jörg dollar von der lmu ins leben
gerufen und hier hat man eben all diese
formate die du vorhin schon erwähnt hast
vereint also es gibt einen youtube kanal
ist gebaut cast und es gibt eine app mit
vorlesungen auch mal kürzeren themen
videos und interviews oder einfach
sachen die sich die user gewünscht haben
und herrn dollar überträgt seine
seminare auch im livestream auf youtube
und hat mir erzählt wie so einen kurs
abläuft
und so haben wir dann so bis zu 15
abonnenten die dazu schauen und live mit
uns chatten während andere im
seminarraum sitzen und wenn dann jemand
was rein schreibt dann sehe ich das auf
einem tablett weil ich das mit verfolgt
und dann gehe ich gleich auf diese frage
ein und sagt youtube nutzerin sonst so
kann man gerne auch anonym machen fragt
folgen die frage dann lest die frage vor
und sagt was meinen die anderen dazu im
chat im präsenzseminar oder was meine
ich dazu dr nada ist also voll auf der
höhe der zeit was sagen denn die
studierenden sowie finden die das auch
mal wirklich gut also herrn aller macht
in seinen kursen noch
umfragen dazu und letztes semester haben
echt knapp 90 sondern studieren denen
gesagt dass sie dieses konzept auch
gerne in anderen kursen hätten
das klingt ja auch so bequem aber kann
es nicht irgendwie auch sein dass die
studierenden nur noch von zu hause im
bett zu teilen sondern einfach gar nicht
mehr in die uni könne man gar keine
neuen leute mehr drin
ja also herr nolle hat schon gesagt dass
die anwesenheit forschung kurs ein
bisschen runter geht's aber die
digitalisierung ist natürlich nicht das
klassische uni leben so wie wir es jetzt
kennen also auch wenn man sich überlegt
wie die uni der zukunft aussehen könnte
das hat mir auch gesagt das sind einfach
die mittel immer besser die
übertragungsgeschwindigkeit wird größer
die generation der professorin person
verjüngen sich also digitale tipps ich
glaube aber auch dass die traditionelle
präsenz lehre nie ausgedient haben wird
weil es doch immer was anderes ist wenn
man die professorin dem professor
einfach in echt körperlich auch vor sich
ziehen
die klassische uni so wie wir sie kennen
wird also wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht
aussterben
hoffentlich in den nächsten jahren mit
mehr biss mehr von solchen projekten
geben das uni ein bisschen digitaler
wird vielen dank die annika